[Music]
today's question comes from michelle
in kentucky while john checks his email
i'll uh take care of you kind folks here
you go i'm working on my masters in
public administration with a 389 gpa
i value what i accomplished and would
like to maintain this gpa through my
remaining courses my career path is
teaching at a college level after after
so maintaining my academic performance
is crucial
my husband doesn't view the importance
of gpa the way i do and he wants me to
get a part-time job if i go to school
full-time without working i can finish
the degree in about eight months if i
work part-time while finishing the
degree it will take 14 months
imagining my gpa going down
while working and going to school at the
same time is beyond horrific to me
my husband says my future employer will
also look at my other qualifications so
i can afford to go down a bit in the gpa
scale
he believes my master's degree is just
another piece of paper how can i
convince my husband that my chosen
career field takes academic performances
seriously ouch
wow john a lot of emotion dripping off
of those
words this is the first of all before
you dive into this because this is
clearly a relationship question yes but
can we talk about the fact that there's
an assumption here
and i'm not taking sides here but
there's an assumption that the gpa has
to go down
yes i mean so the gpa is the proxy here
so just for anyone you
you want your professor
to have made good grades if they're
gonna be a professor right absolutely i
want the pilot of my plane to have not
wrecked planes right does not have
crashed so yes it if you want to be a
professor someday gpa matters
and the gpa has nothing to do with going
what's going on here i've got you've got
a husband that you don't believe values
what you want to do professionally
and you don't value
his concerns he wants you to contribute
financially
and you want to study full-time so this
the the the career can the gpa the
part-time those are all proxies to a
couple who is on two different pages
and this is one of those things that you
got to
hold the presses and you all got to sit
down and talk about where our
relationship so we got two fears here
john tell me if i'm wrong we've got
she's afraid of the gpa
going down if she works part-time yep
he's afraid if she goes full-time school
that their budget's going to be too
tight or that life is going to suck
unimaginably they have two fears
competing those are the two proxy fears
the two real fears are
either uh my wife's gonna be smarter
than me
my wife's going to
i don't want to lose her to graduate
school
i
miss the old fun crazy us and now she's
studying all the time that's the fear
her fear is i don't want to my gpa to go
down i worked full-time throughout my
graduate school and i got a 4-0 in
graduate school not undergrad but in
grad school so that's not a true
statement here what is a true statement
is
your husband doesn't respect what you're
doing
you haven't um
told your husband this is why this is
important to me this is what i want to
do or maybe you have and he's blowing
you off and so how can i convince my
husband that i'll just stop the answer
right that you can't
you can't convince somebody of something
else in fact we're in a world now where
if you put data on the table it just
further entrenches somebody in their
other positions no matter what yeah if
you say on twitter that the sun is hot
you'll have four people
reply instantly and go well that's
technically not true right and then
you'd say well here it's 118 degrees in
in my town right now and they'd go yeah
see that's the problem
it doesn't matter what you put on the
table i agree it's so all it says this
isn't a conversation about data and
facts this is a conversation about
relationship yeah and this is you you
saying not how can i convince you
but let me tell you what i'm
experiencing right now i'm experiencing
a tug a tension between what i want to
do
and my husband not respecting what i
want to do yeah and the path it's going
to take me to get there sit down stay
we'll have a hard conversation and just
talk about your fears and your dreams
and let's match them up yep because this
is not that hard to solve no but
appreciate the questions well it is hard
to solve if you want to use an idiot and
that happens a lot if one of you is a
bonehead or like
well of course everything's hard to
solve if you're an idiot that's true
john thank you for the salient salient
advice and wisdom i'll be here all week